Elon Musk is feuding with a former employee
he responded to a Twitter employee asking
if he still had a job the employees
had he been locked out of his account
and HR wasn't telling him if he'd actually
been fired or not what then took place was
essentially an exit interview it ended with
musk calling into question the employee's
disability and the employee confirming
he had indeed been let go it's the most
public uh in a series of unceremonious firings
that have left Twitter employees very much in
the large Claire's with me Clair Duffy is
in New York when I read this this morning
um I I I sort of felt very sad for the employee
particularly when musk then promptly attacked him
perhaps unfairly and certainly discriminatory
right Richard I mean this is this is uh he's
just sort of shocking you know to see the world's
richest man calling out an employee who has just
been let go from his company and sort of mocking
his disability and I think this is this situation
is really characteristic of how these Twitter
layoffs have happened you have this employee
who's confused about whether he's been laid off
or not in the first place uh you know has to go
to Twitter to ask Elon Musk about it because
he's not getting response from the company and
then musk responds by mocking his disability
and this is an employee who was the founder
of a company that was acquired by Twitter who has
been recognized for his charitable work improving
wheelchair accessibility it just you know seems
sort of characteristic of musk's management style
here okay right but Claire how unusual is this is
is this a one-off I know you've been talking to
other Twitter employees what's the if you like the
underlying tone right Richard so this this is not
a one-off musk has previously mocked employees
previously on Twitter uh and I think the thing
that I'm hearing from employees former employees
is just the sense of confusion uncertainty that
has really characterized the last year of working
for the company I sat down recently with three
former Twitter employees one of the interesting
things though that I asked was what their initial
reaction was to musk's involvement with the
company about a year ago let's take a listen
at the time I did think he had something important
to offer to the company perhaps A New Perspective
that could have been really interesting Justine
decare spent more than three years as an engineer
at Twitter Ben Mali a former engineer on Twitter's
core technology team was pregnant with her first
child throughout the months of uncertainty over
musk's Twitter takeover we were on the Twitter
coaster the Elon Musk chapter for seven months
and during that time he was in he was out it was
happening it wasn't happening I was just trying to
preserve my peace to be honest I was pregnant my
priority was the health of my child what were
you hearing from Twitter's current leadership
throughout the months of the back and forth is
he going to is he not going to we have no idea
if layoffs anything about layoffs that was the
number one question everybody asked the former
employee said Twitter's leadership at the time was
vague about the possibility of layoffs following
musk's takeover but musk himself assuaged some
of their concerns in an all hands meeting he
attended with employees in June he joined in all
hands and he said significant contributors had
nothing to worry about about layoffs regarding
layoffs so you know of course I'm I thought
well then I don't have anything to worry about
because I'm a significant contributor there had
been these promises made labor attorney Shannon
Lis Reardon represents about 1500 former Twitter
employees taking legal action against the company
including the three CNN spoke with she says the
company broke promises following musk's Takeover
in particular offering workers a smaller severance
package than employees had previously been told
they would get so to keep people there they made
these promises they reassured them they put it in
writing they said it in response to questions at
all hands meetings that didn't happen and these
promises were made to people to keep them there
when the market was different last summer Twitter
has opposed some of the legal claims saying its
layoffs were lawful and pushing for private
arbitration instead of a court battle how
did you find out how did you hear that you were
getting laid off I was on one of the tiger teams
that was working on the new Twitter blue and so it
had just been a really long week like I remember
one night at that week like I had stayed up all
night working on this thing and so that night
I had just submitted a code change and maybe an
hour later I like heard of some of my co-workers
they were posting hey my laptop has this really
weird screen on and I can't log in and they were
like in London so and slowly we realized what
was happening and we just got on a Google meet
together and watched everybody drop like flies
it was a really weird sense of whiplash obviously
you have massive layoffs at many of the big Tech
Giants is that something that you're running into
as I'm lovingly put it the
market is hot garbage right now
um I was sitting down earlier this week after
a wave of rejections and I was kind of like wow
maybe you know maybe I should go be a firefighter
or something Ali gave birth to her first child
in January days after her official termination
date from Twitter and was left without the five
months of maternity leave she was expecting she
says she was also left without health insurance
which wasn't included in Twitter's Severance offer
but I would like for us to be compensated fairly
a lot of us put in a lot of effort because
yes we love the company and we love to excel
you know I think what you're hearing there
Richard is just the sort of frustration that
employees stuck with the company throughout the
last year of uncertainty over this acquisition and
then we're let go which really you know upended
people's lives they were kicked out into this
Tech labor market that's now really challenging
and and they say the company hasn't provided the
kind of severance that had previously promised
them it's fascinating thank you you'll keep
watching that for us and come back when there's
more to report thank you very much glad Duffy